>> Brad Neuberg mini--I don't--Brad's actually
a relatively newcomer to SVG. You'd been doing
SVG for a year and a half, two years, but
I think a lot of us already know his name
because of the work that he's done with SVG
web and advocacy within Google and he's just--he's
very--he's another passionate person about,
about the open web. He started a mailing lists
called the--well, I guess a project, the Open
Web Project and he's really helping move SVG
and other open web technologies forward. So,
I just want to thank Brad for helping set
up this conference at Google and I want to
welcome him to the stage to do his key note.
>> NEUBERG: So, sorry for the technical difficulties,
I'm giving this about an hour earlier than
expected. Any--bring this guy up from sleep.
So while we wait, I know we've got people
from all over the world here, people have
communicated--have traveled from all over.
So who here is coming from Europe? Wow. Wow.
So who is here from the States? And who's
right here from California? Nice. And some
other places, just yell out that you might
be from. Australia. Nice. Canada. North Carolina.
Okay. Yeah, we have some folks from Japan.
Yeah? Welcome. Where are you from in Japan?
Where in Japan? Tokyo. Nice. And how many
of you--is this your first SVG Open? Yeah,
right. I don't believe this guy here. And
who has been to every single SVG Open that's
ever happened? Yeah. The organizer.
>> So for those of you who didn't see that--I
think the lone hand that raised up, that was
Andreas Neumann who started this conference
series in 2002 and who has been a huge SVG
advocate. So I would--everybody, a round of
applause for Andreas Neumann. .
>> NEUBERG: Okay, looks like weíve got
slides. So, hi, thanks everyone for being
here. My name is Brad Neuberg. I'm with Google.
Today, I'm going to be talking about a variety
of things. I'm going to talk about how we
used SVG at Google, why we're excited about
it, and some of the work that we've been doing
with Internet Explorer to enable SVG. So starting,
I just want to say, this is a really exciting
time, in some ways, I'm relatively new to
the SVG community and it feels like there's
a real renaissance happening. I'll touch more
on that, but this year and next year, we're
seeing everything from all of the browsers,
of Firefox, Safari Chrome, Opera, all having
SVG implementations. We're seeing real authoring
tools like Inkscape; Adobe Illustrator has
good import and export. We're seeing real
adoption and interest and this is kind of
writing a general wave, the last year and
a half we're really seeing HTML 5 take off,
CSS3, Web Fonts, so it's really an exciting
time. And before I kind of get into the bulk
of some of the steps, I want to talk about--I
want to really acknowledge, I think SVG has
a really special history. I've been to a lot
of computer communities and this one; I'm
just really blown away by the kind of level
of passion and the level of commitment. And
I want to briefly kind of call out to some
of the folks who I think really worked in
the 2005-2006 time period or kind of talk
about some of the work our group is doing
and how we arrived at SVG. But I look back
at the folks working in 2005-2006 and I think
these are the folks that were really doing
this out of a labor of love, really helped
move things forward to that next step which
is why we're here at the sort of beginning
of this renaissance. So, I want to kind of
briefly call out some of their names. I know
I'm going to miss some people. Like, I said
this is a great community. There are a lot
of folks doing lots of cool stuff. So, I briefly
want to call out--some of the folks--well,
I already did too many but Jon Cruz, obviously,
him and the team of Inkscape. If you havenít
checked out Inkscape, it's a pretty amazing
piece of open source software. Of course,
everyone involved with the Firefox, SVG implementation,
I think they really came out with a really
strong work, one of the first folks to really
bring this in the browsers. Everyone involved
in WebKit, in Opera, bringing those implementations
to light. And then no community is complete
without the evangelist, the people writing
books, the people writing articles. I've gotten
here some of the stories about organizing
this conference year after year. It's a volunteer
created conference of--I've watched them in
action. It's pretty amazing all over the world
putting this together. So, I'm just sort of--I
want to call out some of the names of folks
who I've really seen--really being evangelists.
And, you know, working the nights, working
the weekends because they believe in this
technology. So, I just want to kind of give
them a shout out, of course, and more, I know
I miss people. So, if I did, please give yourself
a pat on the back. So I want to share a personal
story. In 2004, early 2005, I was a dynamic
HTML hacker. I was a JavaScript guy, and this
was before the fancy name AJAX. It was not
an easy time to a be a JavaScript person or
a DHTML person. Weíve got Alex over here
and I think he can call it the great dark
ages of DHTML as some of us call it. And the
reason I bring it up, I think there's a lot
of parallels with SVG. I remember 2004, going
to the bookstore, looking for books on DHTML
and they were all out of print. I remember
I was at the startup company at that time
and we had a web based aggregator for fees,
and I remember saying, "Hey, why don't we
use DHTML and this XTMLHP request thing. We
didn't have a shorter name for that, yet.
You had to say the full thing. Let's make
something more interactive and people laughed
at me. And they say, "Hey, DHTML, that's dead.
That's buggy. That's not enough places." And
then, of course, we all know history, 2005
rolls around. Sites like Flicker, Google maps
helps legitimize DHTML and gives it a nice
new name AJAX and the rest is history. Suddenly
everyone woke up and said, "Hey, wow. This
stuff is all over the place." We can get real
work done. And the interesting thing about
DHTML and AJAX is that it really was invented
by Microsoft in 1997 with Outlook Web Access.
And it took about eight years for folks to
kind of wake up and realize, "Hey, I can use
this stuff. I can do real work. I can get
interesting things done." And so a renaissance
really happened with DHTML and the same thing
is happening with SVG. I like to kind of paraphrase
Gandhi--I know it's a little overused, but
I think it's overused because there's truth
to it. I'm kind of paraphrasing Gandhi, the
famous thing: first, they ignore you, and
then they hype the heck out of you. Then they
leave you for dead and then suddenly you're
getting real work done. Okay. DHTML went through
the same thing. If for some reason, web technologies
have to go through this worse than everything
else, JavaScript went through the same thing.
JavaScript was a shunned language. CSS went
through the same thing. You know, in 2001
talking about CSS, you know, you had to wear
one of those asbestos suits. So, I want to,
you know, now, that I've kind of shared that,
that really I think the parallels are very
strong with DHTML. I want to just briefly
talk about why is Google excited. Why are
we so excited about SVG? Well, I don't think
it's been a secret that we're excited about
the web; we're excited about HTML 5. And generally,
when we use the term HTML 5, it's kind of
determining the end of the term AJAX for better
or worse that--like a larger term. It's not
just the spec. And it's becoming a bit of
a place holder for all these great web technology
that can really advance things forward. The
formal HTML 5 spec, things like Geolocation,
Web Fonts, SVGs, CSS3, faster JavaScript,
we're rally bullish on HTML 5 and this whole
family of technologies because we see it solving
real problems. One of the most exciting formal
aspects of HTML 5, the spec, is that it now
allows you to drop SVG right into a normal
HTML page. SVG just becomes more tags that
you can add to HTML, but now everything doesn't
have to be a box, and everything doesn't have
to be a Div [PH] or a table. Now, you have
circles and rectangles. It's kind of a straightforward
idea and we should have had it a long time
ago. But now that we are going to have it
and that's really exciting. You know, I think--we're
a search company. I know sometimes we do things
that we're not--you know, we're doing things
outside of search but we like things that
are human readable, that are text friendly
because they're searchable and SVG is very
searchable. Especially, you know, someone
once asked me, "Why would I want to search
a vector image?" If it's an illustration of
a tiger, you don't want to search that. If
it's a medical diagram, if it's electoral
results for the last election we just went
through, these are interesting things we want
in search results. And what makes SVG so cool
is it's not just images, but hyperlinks can
be inside and point inside of them. That stuff
that can be used for Pagerink for signals,
that's interesting. There's a market demand
for SVG and vector graphics on the web. I
want to share this story a little bit later
for why the group I'm on chose vector graphics
and SVG, in particularly the first one. But
folks want to be able to do drawing on the
web. They want SVG in canvass. I'll talk about
both of those in a bit. There's a clear market
demand, and so, developers want this. Another
reason Google is so excited and bullish about
SVG is it integrates; it works with the rest
of the web stack. It integrates with CSS and
HTML and JavaScript. You donít have to
learn a whole new set of technologies, you
learn this--you use the skills you already
know. So that's really exciting, that level
of integration, I think that we're going to
start seeing more and more interesting things
because it's not just trapped within a little
box. It's really a part of the browser. One
of the other reasons is SVG is a View Source
Technology. So View Source technologies doesn't
mean that you have the right to, you know,
look at everyone's source code. But it does
mean that it makes it much easier to learn
from what other people are doing. I have found
this so much in the last year and a half.
I'll see a cool demo from Doug or from Rick
Masters, or a lot of the folks here in this
community and I'll say, "How the heck did
they do that?" I just go to View Source. I
learn from what they're doing. That's really
powerful, and that really underguards the
web itself. And then if it's open source,
it's easy, you cut and paste. You like that
gradient, grab the definition. If it's an
open source font and the definition is right
in the file, cut and paste that. That's really
cool. And finally, we're excited about SVG
because it's easy to import and export. That
means you don't get trapped into any specific
tool. And it's also very server-friendly.
You can throw up a PHP Script, a Google App
Engine site that emits SVG as easily as you
do HTML. It's much harder to omit binary objects,
but you can use any standard templating language
to spit out a little bit of SVG, especially
with HTML5 because you can mix it in line.
So now that you know a little bit about why
we're excited about SVG, let's look at, you
know, where we're putting our sort of--our
commitment to it. How are we actually using
SVG? I'm just going to show you a few of the
places. One of them is, I donít know who
here is--so, in Google Docs, you can actually
drop illustrations in and you have kind of
a lightweight diagramming and drawing tool,
which is great if you're trying to explain
something. Had anyone gotten the chance to
play with this, awesome. This uses SVG. It
uses SVG on every web browser. It has to use
VML and IE, but we use SVG on all the other
browsers. Here's an example drawing. My drawing
skills are pretty lousy, so I had to find
someone else to give me a good drawing. My
original one was like a happy face and someone
was like, "That does not look very good."
So last night, I'm like, "Who has a picture?"
Another place we use is something called the
Google Visualization API. This is a really
cool API that you can give a data from many
different kinds of data sources. JASON, XML,
on the URL, a Google spreadsheet, and it will
give you different kinds of visualizations.
Well, this is a perfect used case for SVG.
And some of the visualizations do use SVG.
Let me show you some of these.
This right--this right here is actually--it's
called the gauge. It's a visualization alternating
into a gauge. You give it the right E values,
and you're actually looking at a Google spreadsheet
that has what is known as a gadget. And that
gadget has the visualization in it. Turtles
[PH] all the way down. And these gauges are
actually SVGs. So as we change the size, it
still stays beautiful. That's the scaleable
aspect. And it's actually, the gauges are
keeping track of memory in CPUs. So that's
one of them. Here's another nice one, a simple
pie chart, click in and get the breakdown.
The cool thing about the Google Visualization
API, it's very easy to use. You can even just
give it a URL and it will return back the
results of what you're looking at. So it's
very straightforward to use. One of the final
places we use SVG is we have, you know, like
most companies--we've got an extensive set
of JavaScript libraries. And one of them has
a cross-browser drawing abstraction that uses
SVG on every browser. Again, it does use VML
and IE, and that gives you a standard way
to do drawing. And a lot of our products use
that as a consistent API. So these are some
of the places that we use SVG internally.
I want to share a little bit about the group
that I'm on and sort of get into some of the
work we've been doing. I'm on a group called
Open Web Advocacy. Our motto is help web technologies
get better faster, and depending if we're
on a good mood or not. Sometimes it's; help
web technologies get better faster. Sometimes
it's; help web technologies suck less better
faster, depending if we're happy or not. But
our job is to really get out there and educate,
evangelize. A lot of us have a JavaScript
background, so we create JavaScript toolkits
that help bring along other browsers so we
can have more parity because it's hard for
developers to use a new technology if it's
not everywhere, so helping the chicken and
egg problem. So we wear a lot of different
hats. And about--we are--our group started
about a year ago. And when we kicked off,
we were like, "What should we focus on first?"
each of us sort of attacked different problem
sets. And on my side, I said, "What do developers
want?" So, I went to something called the
OpenAjax Alliance's Browser Wish List. It's
a very cool survey that was done a while back.
Actually, another one is coming up. And this
asked a tremendous number of developers, "What
do you want?" If you could grab the browser
makers by the lapels and say, "Here's what
I want." What would that be? And what do you
think the number one request by far that everything
else above--across the domain requests, other
various kinds of things. What do you think
the number one request was? I donít know.
What do you--Doug, what do you think it was?
>> VML?
>> NEUBERG: The VML? So the number one request
was we want web vector graphics. Specifically,
we want SVG and the canvas tag on every browser.
That was the number one request. So that made
our job easy. We said, "Here's the number
one request. Let's take a look at that." My
background again is in JavaScript. Like I
said, I generally end up getting browsers
to do things they weren't really designed
to do. And so, I said, "We already have some
JavaScript help for the canvas tag on IE that
Erik Arvidson, Emil Eklund and other folks
at Google had worked on. I said, "What can
we do with SVG? How can we help SVG? So sort
of--if I had only known what it would take.
Sort of delved down into that in terms of
how can we help bring along IE on this front.
Because I want to get into--we've seen amazing
progress. And one of the things I want to
share too, a year ago too, I said, "Where
is SVG?" I've always been a fan of it. I said,
"Where does it come from?" And last year,
I was blown away when I looked back at the
state of the community. I was like, "Wow,
there are implementations everywhere." We've
got Authoring Tools. We've got this excited
community and real stuff happening. Wikipedia
which we'll talk about and Brion is also here
for the conference. He's doing an amazing
work with SVG, the sixth largest site on the
web. I was blown away at how much had happened.
So I want to--and I said, what can help us
get to that next step. What's the next sort
of progression to help things go forward?
Before getting into that, I do want to say,
I don't want to beat up Mark [INDISTINCT].
I really respect that they came to the conference
this year. I really respect that they're here
having a dialogue, sending real people. I
think we should give them a round of applause.
I think that's really cool. I hope that's
not embarrassing. I'm embarrassing them. I'm
embarrassing them. I know for many JavaScript
hackers, we've learned DHTML on IE. I know
I did. So I think it's really cool to have
you here at the event this year. At the same
time, one of the things that is blocking SVG
from going to that next step is we've got
this awesome implementations but we donít
have them on IE yet. And that is hurting developers
who are bursting at the seams to deploy stuff
with this. So finding some kind of realistic
way to help address that issue was one of
the things our team wanted to look at. And
one of the--the other point is a little subtle.
The fact that SVG doesn't work in the 99.9%
of DHMTL that's out there. This is not an
appropriate time to get into XHTML versus
HTML, but I'd like to say when you go in and
you're getting a PhD thesis, your research
adviser says, "Choose one research topic."
If you show up and you got two or three novel
things, they'll say, "Go back to the drawing
board." Chaining SVG to XHTML is two research
topics at the minimum. It's saying, they both
have to succeed or they both unfortunately
fail. We were saying can we uncouple this,
allow SVG to be used in normal HTML and let
them sort of, you know, fight for their own
merits in that sense. So that was one of the
other primary things that developers sometimes
wanted to just drop a few tags. They want
to square with rounded rectangles to make
a button that doesnít need some crazy way
to get rounded rectangles that you can just
use a little SVG. So we saw that as the second
blocker. So our solution for both was a JavaScript
library. Before I kind of take you into that
and show you some demos, I want to say that
we're not the only ones doing this. There
are a lot of really amazing toolkits in the
community, they're all speaking at this conference.
I'm going to run through them really quick.
All of them are taking different approaches
to give you a consistent way to draw SVG on
all browsers including Internet Explorer.
And itís a real testament to the fact that
there's real demand for this and people are
actually, you know, I call it, you know, "Vote
with your sweat." It's kind of a crazy term,
but if you believe in something, shift code
and people are, so people think this is important.
Obviously, the Raphael Library doing really
amazing work. And theyíre speaking today,
this morning in this room, make sure to catch
that. DojoX, doing some very cool work, they
have a different pluggable back-in, so you
can have different kinds of renderers and
it integrates with the rest of the Dojo infrastructure,
so you get Data Abstraction. You can do some
really cool stuff, again, 12 o'clock today
in this room. And then the Apple SDK, Segay
Linskey [PH] is doing some very interesting
work in terms of a consistent development
environment. Again, that's also being talked
about in this room today. So I encourage you
to check out the work they're doing. So, let's
jump in to what we're involved in. So the
name of the library is the SVG Web Library.
And what makes this unique is there's nothing
extra to download. We, you can either say
use or abuse. We use facilities that are already
present on about 97% percent of the web browsers
out there. So there's nothing for the user
to download. And we give the illusion of native
SVG support for both static and dynamic SVG
images. And itís as easy as dropping a
JavaScript file into your page so that users
donít have to download new software, it
just works. So before this toolkit, you have
roughly about 30% coverage for SVG, that's
essentially adding up the other browsers.
Once you've got the toolkit, you essentially
have close to 100% of the installed web base,
probably closer to 95%, but we'll round up
5%, truth in advertising. That's cool because
that means that as a developer, you donít
face the chicken and egg problem, you can
just start using the technology you're interested
in and get stuff done. Now, I want to mention--I've
done a fair bit of open source, and this has
been a really exciting project. We've got
more people outside of Google working on this
than inside. We've got Rick Masters who's
actually here, one of the lead developers.
He'll be actually coming up a little bit later
in the presentation to show us some cool demos.
We've got James Hight, who does not--he's
a giant Z. I couldnít get a picture of
him in time. And we've just got a whole host
of folks in the community just actively putting
this through its paces. I want to mention
that we've made a lot of progress with SVG
web. It is an Alpha. This is an Early Access.
As we continue working with folks as they
put it to its paces, and Sam is using it on
his blogs. Shelly Powers is using it for some
cool stuff. We'll talk about some of the work
we're doing with Wikipedia around using this.
We're going to be like open source. We'll
announce data when it's, you know, actually
3.0 because that's the open source way. So
let me show you some demos. [PAUSE] So this
is Firefox and this is native SVG. These images
are from Flicker, weíre seeing, we can
do stuff with the mouse with them. You could
imagine building a more larger App with photo
pickers and so on.
I should mention that the library works on
I6, 7, and 8, so we've got complete coverage.
This is I8, if we jump over to IE, we see
the exact same demo running with the same
fidelity in IE.
And this is not just SVG, there's JavaScript
that lives in this, the JavaScript thinks
that there's really native support in the
browser. Let's see another sample. I really
like this one. Shelly Powers put this together
a few weeks ago. I like it because it's one
of those "gets-real-done" kinds of things.
So Shelly, she's got a blog and she wants
to put an image in the background. And she
wants it to scale based on the size of the
browser, straightforward, right? If you use
a bitmap image, it will get ugly based on
how it is, it will get distorted. She'd loved
to use SVG in the background, well, now she
can. This--in the background is from the Open
Clipart Library. As we change the size of
the browser, we get that nice scaling quality
of SVG. Of course, that's SVG web in the background
doing that. Michael Noitz [PH]--at the end
of this I'll put up--when he's talking, he's
doing some really cool work with mapping,
things like that. This is a sample that he
helped port, I think someone wrote the original
one. What I like about it is it shows a couple
of different things. It actually shows demographics.
It shows the population of Germany at different
times. And SVG is really good at this. It's
rich data, you slice and dice. This is directly
integrated into the HTML. The SVG is in normal
HTML. And we see the HTML updating as we do
it. What makes this really cool is some people
are like, "You know, why don't you just use
an image? Well, on the fly, we can change
the language. And we are changing it to Russian
inside of the SVG. Here, we are changing it
to French. And that's cool. And that depends
on the SVG, again it's just text, so it's
easy to change the language. It's easy to
make this intelligent, and that's a cool thing.
I know, Brion is excited about these kinds
of thing. He'll mention some cool things that
they're doing. You know, SVG and maps go together
like peanut butter and jelly. It's one of
those classic uses of SVG. Michael Noitz [PH]
will talk about more about this in his talk.
He's been creating an interactive overview
of the election results for the German election
that I believe happened last week. It happened
fairly recently, I see all the folks whoa
re from that area nodding, getting that right.
We see Germany. We can zoom in and out. We
can pan around. We can slice and dice the
data. Again, this is another good example
of--SVG is on the left doing what it does
well. HTML on the right directly embedded
in the page. This is in Safari. And I'll mention--I'm
going to talk a little bit later and more
in the technical talk in the afternoon, but
SVG web also helps the native browsers actually
by letting you drop SVG in the normal HTML.
It doesnít just help IE, it also helps
you put in the normal HTML. And actually patches
over a couple of bugs too. So it helps the
native stuff too. So these are also using
SVG web. And then here we are in IE, we can
still zoom in., we can still slice and dice.
And now this developer can deploy his work
and know it's going to reach folks. I like
this one. I'm a horrible space geek, don't
get me started. I'll talk your ear off. Luther
Hoffman put this together. It uses the Google
Maps API to figure out your latitude and longitude,
and then it generates--we're turning off the
lights like we're outside. It generates a
star map. These are the stars that we would
see right above us based on where we are,
and that is generated with SVG. Again, real
work, getting real stuff done, and this is
running on IE but you almost don't even notice.
It just works. The user doesnít really
care what the technology is, it just works
now. So here's a couple of demos.
I spoke a little bit about how JavaScript
is tricked. One of the cool things about the
toolkit is JavaScript that runs in the page
thinks that there's native SVG support. So
you get things like get on it by ID, creating
an element. And so, one of the slight nuances
when working with SVG is you have to kind
of give the name space. So you create an element.
And we actually--we plugged this global variable
"svgns" into the page, because almost everyone
defines that anyway. So that can make it easier
for people to just start using this. Things
like style work. So you can grab your circle
from the page. Again, treat it like you do
HTML, ".style.fill" just works. We support
a huge amount of the "DOM". This--I'm just
giving you some small representative samples.
You'd be bored if I went through, you know,
first child, last child, child node. So this
is a few of the--of the methods and, of course,
event listeners, and including when you're
on IE, when you're dealing with SVG, you can
use "addEventListener". So the end-result
of this is things just work for the programmer.
And I--I'm not going to go super deep into
how this is achieved. I don't know if you
know this picture. This is a famous illustration
from the Apollo-Soyuz "Peace in Space." I
think 1976, the peace between the superpowers.
Under the covers in SVG web, I like to say
"Do you want the blue pill or the red pill?"
I don't remember which is which. The blue
pill is that it just works, you feel like
you got SVG, you have to do some slight finagling
to accommodate SVG web, but it's pretty minor.
The red pill is--we use Flash to do the rendering
not--you know, we do it for purely pragmatic
reasons. I'd like to say I'm a pragmatic person
following ideological goals. We do it because
it's going to be installed where we need it
on the IE instances. And then we use a technology
called Microsoft Behaviors, which are very
cool. I've long been a fan of them. They've
been around for a long time. They essentially
allow you to extend the layout engine of IE
and do some very nifty stuff. And if you're
into such things, pull me aside. We've installed
some pretty long standing issues with Microsoft
behaviors to make them much more robust. So
kind of got some--if you're in to JavaScript
hacking, there are some fun--some fun solutions
we've found. But the end-result is that these
two things come together and you get the illusion
of native SVG, including like ".style" for
example, which looks like magic headers and
setters. And I'll touch a little bit more
on this in the tech talk in the afternoon.
I want to briefly talk about performance.
SVG web is--it's not a get-out-of-jail free
card for IE. We--it would be great to have
SVG in IE9. The--the library will always be
slower than native support, by definition
as a JavaScript library. And we've made some
amazing progress where we can power some really
cool things, but we'll always hit an upper
ceiling. We're just a JavaScript toolkit.
So we can help carry the ball for a little
bit, but the native implementations will always
be vastly faster. And this is only going to
enable users to interact with SVG content,
but it will not match the performance of a
native implementation. So--let me show you
some more demos. [PAUSE] Oh, you just saw
the more demos. I did those in the wrong order.
And I also wanted to point out Michael Noitz
[PH], who is our--the demographic one and
the map example. He's going to be going deeper
into the work he's doing. He's been a great
member of the community, tomorrow in the other
room, Maxwell Tech Talk. I want to just briefly
touch on how a developer works with this.
And if you're interested in this, come to
the Tech Talk. I'm going to be essentially
taking you through all the steps to get going
with SVG web. But you've got two ways to embed
into the page. You can use the object tag,
which will also work on IE. We have that working
on IE. And you just say, "This is SVG." And
then you set data equal to "Here's what I
actually want to show." Or you can directly
embed into the page. Now, we do something
that's interesting. Let me--let me take you
through this page. This is an HTML5 page.
That's the HTML5 doc type at the top. HTML5
gives you two ways to embed XML-like data.
The first one is you actually can put it into
a script tag and set to mime-type. The second
one is SVG becomes a native tag. You just
say "SVG" and you drop it in. We currently
support the first one for a variety of reasons
in terms of reliability. And that's what you're
seeing here. We will eventually like to support
the second version, but there are some tricky
engineering issues. But the nice thing about
this version is you can drop pure unadulterated
SVG right into a normal HTML page. And so
right here, we see that right there. You see
a rectangle. I'm sure everyone here knows.
You've seen this kind of things, setting where
it is, setting its fill. You know what I love?
I didn't put it in this. But if I put "rx"
and "ry", that rounds the corners. And I like
to say "rounded rectangles, I love." In 2009,
we're still waiting for rounded rectangles.
Well, there you go. You got some rounded rectangles
there, didn't have to break a sweat. So I'd
like to invite up Brion Vibber, who is doing
some really cool work at Wikipedia. I'm going
to show a demo of some of the stuff we've
been doing with him after he comes up. But
Brion is the CTO of Wikimedia. It is a real
pleasure to have him here. It's a really big
booster of SVG.
>> VIBBER: Hi there, everybody. So you probably
heard of Wikipedia before. It's, you know,
people do use it on the Internet. It's a pretty
cool site, as I hope you all think. If you
don't, then--well, that's very sad. But anyway,
we basically do three main things at Wikipedia
and our other sites of Wikimedia foundation,
which is, first, to build educational and
reference materials on the web. Second, to
make those freely available under open-content
licenses, and third, to build them collaboratively
on that wacky Internet, which is really the
most important part where SVG comes into play.
We've been using SVG very heavily on Wikipedia
and Wikimedia comments for the last few years,
because it gives us a standard format for
graphics, which can be edited by multiple
people over time with no, you know, lousiness
or having to start over or having to find
a, you know, very expensive tool such as Adobe
Illustrator. There are free offering tools
that are cross-platformed for SVG. And that
has enabled people to create all kinds of
maps, graphics, icons, diagrams, charts, a
huge portion of the graphics that you see
on Wikipedia are on the back-end built with
SVG. But, traditionally, most of that action
for us has been on the desktop side, because
the browser support just wasn't quite there.
In the last couple of years, we've seen SVG
support come pretty well up to snuff on every
browser except IE. And so, I'm keeping my
fingers crossed for IE9. But we've had, you
know, kind of a big gap where something like
two-thirds, 70% of our viewers just would
not be able to use native SVG in a browser,
which has meant that we haven't been able
to do anything dynamic. We basically have
static images that sit there in your browser.
You know, we actually restorize them in order
to make them most widely available. But there
are so many amazing things that SVG promises
when you actually put it right in the browser.
You can create interactive tools, such as
the maps that Brad was showing earlier, which
would be hugely valuable for a site like Wikipedia,
building an interactive tool where you can
really explore, you know, the data that exists.
Being able to, you know, switch in multiple
versions, different data sets. You can create
a far more compelling educational experience
than, you know, any static image you can create.
Plus, of course, our other goal is that we're
building things on the Internet interactively
collaboratively with multiple people. And
any time that we require people to download
a program to their computer, that is a barrier.
Even if it's available for every operating
system, it is a barrier to entry and it makes
it harder to use. If we can put it in the
browser, bam, suddenly, it's a billion times
easier. We can do, you know, native editing,
you know, where you're moving things around
right there in your browser. We can enable
localization, and support of multiple languages
has always been one of our, you know, most
important things. Wikipedia is available in
200 something languages a lot. I always forget
the number, because it's just too big. But,
you know, being able to create a chart once
and then fill in all those localized strings,
all those localized names make that available
natively for every language, wow. I mean we
really, really want to do that, but we've
never been able to do it because, you know,
it's just not going to be available for 70%
of our users. With SVG web, suddenly that
gap is actually going to be filled. And until
we have a real native support in IE, we have
something that's almost as good. And that's
going to enable us to really make the SVG
experience as it were insanely better. So
I'm really happy about that.
>> NEUBERG: Thank you so much, Brion. It's
cool. It's really, really fun to be working
with Wikipedia, itís like, ìOh, Mark
from Wikipedia,î itís like; I'm a Wiki
geek, so itís like the Mecca of Wikis.
I want to show you some of the work weíve
been doing with Wikipedia. One of the things
most people don't know is that they had this
amazing resource called the Wikipedia Comments.
Every image, video, SVG file, ends up on the
comments there, itís free called, sure,
they're creative comments licensed, and you
can work with them. I want to show you a prototype
that weíve been building with them. That
allows you to not just sort of see the SVG
image on the comments. Here we are, seeing
the Wikimedia Comments logo, but you can actually
begin to interact with it, and take advantage
of the scaleable nature. So, we can pan around,
zoom in and out. We get Google map style controls
and the cool thing is we come over to IE and
there we go.
So, youíll be seeing more of this, you
know, we were work in the QA and move this
forward but expect to see this at some point
in the Wikimedia comments, itís a prototype
right now. And itís just a real honor;
itís very exciting to be working with you
guys. And there are--Brion himself is speaking
this Sunday, in this room, if you want to
go deeper into the work theyíre doing.
And theyíre always looking for volunteers,
doing all sorts of very cool work around this,
definitely see his talk. And I want to invite
one more person up on stage, Rick Masters
is one of the leads of SVG web, he literally,
he saved my butt on this project. The stuff
that he's done is amazing, I remember, you
know, we had originally, we were just going
to hit, much of SVG 1.1 and there were a lot
of things we couldnít hit. I remember I
woke up one Monday morning and it was like,
ìOh, hey, I did SVG fonts over the weekend.î
You know, and then Iíll show up, ìOh,
hey, I just checked in a partial Smile implementation.î
So, all sorts of cool stuff and I--heís
actually the senior architect at F5 networks
and I want to invite him up on stage to show
us some quick demos of--some other cool SVG
web stuff. [PAUSE] Okay. Let me plug-in this
now, okay.